most kids hate school and
many of us would even venture out to say
that school
was or still is torture you know i mean
i hated going to school when i was a kid
it was torture
the question most kids wonder is when
they will
ever use the various things they learn
in school from solving differential
equations
to analyzing the rhetorical devices used
in shakespeare's plays
parents and teachers will tell us that
no education is ever wasted
but this is simply not true from an
objective standpoint jeff bezos has
likely
not written a poem since high school and
dwayne johnson
likely doesn't even remember calculus
moreover
apple doesn't care if you can recite the
gettysburg address
and google doesn't care if you know what
the mitochondria of a cell does
fortunately however we are on the verge
of an educational revolution
and here's what we may see in the next
several years
[Music]
education is important and no one will
argue against that
but at the same time i think most of us
would agree that the educational system
is broken the average cost of attendance
for a public university
is currently over twenty five thousand
dollars per year
while the average cost of attendance for
private schools is over fifty thousand
dollars per year
which translates to 100 grand and over
200 grand
for a traditional four-year degree but
like the dot-com
housing and cryptocurrency bubbles the
educational bubble 2
will pop even before we see a
large-scale artificial intelligence that
will accelerate our learning process
the education system is likely to be
quite different within the next decade
or two
due to the rapid transition away from
formal education
companies including google apple ibm
bank of america starbucks tesla and many
more
have all dropped their degree
requirements and this trend
isn't stopping anytime soon but why now
college has been consistently getting
more expensive
and really hasn't made any fundamental
changes within the last four decades
so why are companies all of a sudden
dropping what many consider to be an
essential
well the two key underlying reasons for
this are the purpose of university and
school in general
as well as the rate of progress to
better understand this shift
we have to first take a look at the two
main things we learned
throughout our educational careers which
are hard skills
and soft skills hard skills are the
actual content we learn
throughout math physics computer science
engineering and so on and so forth
soft skills on the other hand are less
concrete
this includes our social and
communication skills
and our various personality traits and
the thing is
companies never require college degrees
for the hard skills we learn
but rather the soft skills this is
because
hard skills are generally much easier to
learn and teach
thus companies prefer to hire
individuals with strong teamwork and
leadership skills
who can quickly pick up the technical
skills on the job
after all most people learn more during
the first several weeks at their job
compared to the four years at college
and companies know that
and have always known that with that
being said
why did they require degrees to begin
with well
aside from universities providing job
applicants with a solid understanding of
fundamentals
they're also a strong indication of
various soft skills
employers like high gpas not simply
because they show that you have a strong
grasp of the content
but more importantly that you're
hardworking
dedicated and have high standards
similarly
employers don't value internships
because you must have learned so much
coding
and engineering skills but rather
because it shows that you actively seek
out external opportunities
and that you have experience working on
a team on a real project
so the degree requirement over the past
few decades was
mostly driven by soft skills however
after looking for such candidates for
many decades now
most companies have become very good at
identifying these individuals through
other mediums such as interviews
competitions and
other individual accomplishments such as
filing patents or running a successful
local business
as a result employers dependence on
college to determine soft skills has
subsided
at the same time the rate of progress
has also grown exponentially
making the hard skills learn to college
more and more outdated
college and school have always been
several years behind the real world
this is because companies have to
discover the technology
and mainstream the technology before
state legislatures
as well as private institutions
incorporate them into their own
curriculums
as a result the latest technologies
usually don't hit universities
until several years after they're
developed though a slight inconvenience
this wasn't too big of a problem at the
start however
as technology including artificial
intelligence machine learning and even
computer science
advance at exponential rates companies
don't want to have to wait a decade or
more before they get relevant applicants
not to mention the applicants have been
taught outdated information
this trend has consistently increased
the company's role in the training and
education process
from maybe 30 or 40 to 60 70 and 80
as a result when companies can choose
individuals with
strong soft skills without help from
universities
and when they're doing the majority of
the training anyway
why not just bypass college and train
future employees
yourself and that's exactly what's
happening
right now google recently launched its
own career certification program
which they say will hold equal weight to
four-year programs
at least with them instead of covering a
broad range of topics and materials like
a traditional college
google's career certification programs
simply train you for the job
and cuts out everything else currently
they have four different certifications
which include data analyst project
manager ux designer
and iit support specialist the program
is just in its beginning stages
but it's just a matter of time until
they start offering more serious
certifications
such as software engineer and financial
analyst similarly
last year amazon announced that it will
spend 700 million to train
100 000 of their current employees this
investment
includes amazon technical academy which
is supposed to transition technical
employees
to software engineering careers within
the company and beyond
on top of this they also introduce
associated tech
which will transition distribution
workers to tech roles
as their jobs are automated they even
have their own machine learning
university which is taught by 400
machine learning scientists
who work for amazon similar programs are
also available from other leading
companies
such as apple ibm ge and many others
and did i mention that all these
programs only last 6 months
and only cost a couple of hundred
dollars each obviously
these programs are not yet largely
recognized
aside from the companies that are
offering the programs themselves
but they do offer a great opportunity
for individuals
who either can't afford college or don't
want to go in debt to get a degree
moreover even though their certificates
and training
aren't largely accepted experience
working at these companies is largely
accepted
thus if you're able to score a job at
google amazon
or apple with one of these programs
you're set in that field
working at google amazon or apple for
five to ten years
will no doubt put you leagues above the
average job applicant
thus even if you ever get laid off or
want to switch jobs
you can use your experience furthermore
as these companies prove the viability
of such accelerated low-cost programs
by continuing to innovate and advance
their companies the value of these
programs will also exponentially
increase
which will simultaneously decrease the
demand for college degrees
and this will finally get traditional
institutions to also alter the manner
in which they educate to be more
efficient and cost effective
if they want to be a competitive option
to the vast majority of people
of course certain programs will continue
to only be offered by universities such
as medicine
and law however the vast majority of
tech jobs
which is the vast majority of our
futures will likely switch over to
certifications
and programs offered by companies as
opposed to traditional school
over the next 10 to 20 years this is not
all good though though this will make
several high-paying jobs more accessible
to the average individual
this will also significantly increase
the competition for these jobs
this may also saturate the market thus
lowering pay for these jobs
across the field so this can very well
hurt the average employee
as it will become more difficult to get
a job and they will get paid less
however from a societal perspective this
is very beneficial
as it drives innovation due to more
competition
but anyways taking a look at a larger
scope view of education
we are likely to see even larger
disruptions within the next 20 to 50
years through the help of artificial
intelligence and of course
one of the most well-known and hyped
companies within this field
is elon musk's neurolink neurolink was
founded in 2016
with the goal to merge computers with
the human brain to transform our brains
into super computers
right now the neural link and one
implant has been revealed to sit behind
one's ear
and have electrodes that are threaded
into the brain we have already seen
neural
technology that is capable of both
interpreting and stimulating neurons
within the brain
for instance we have already seen
several demonstrations in which such
technology
has been used to control robotic arms
and legs using nerve endings that are
still intact
as for exactly how neurolink will
interact with our brains
their implants currently use very thin
flexible wires
which are much thinner than human hair
follicles these wires will be
essentially be sewn into our brains
using sewing machines though that sounds
really scary
and dangerous it's actually not as scary
as it sounds
and using such machinery is the only way
to mainstream this technology safely
as doing it manually requires conducting
brain surgery
moreover the threading of such wires
with the brain
requires very fine motor skills which is
very difficult to do by hand
anyways after these wires are sewn onto
the brain
the other side will be connected to a
superchip which is of course
the most crucial portion of the product
success currently
the main concern with the superchip is
actually receiving
accurate signals from the brain itself
electrical signals from the brain
are already very small themselves as the
brain
is literally as efficient as a light
bulb thus
the electrical signals within the brain
are very small
and tough to sense on top of this when
this signal
is being transmitted through a very thin
wire the chances of distortion
exponentially increase with the length
of the wire thus
it's essential that the superchip is as
close to the source as possible
but with all of this in place what have
they been able to accomplish
well last year elon musk announced that
they were able to get a monkey to
control a computer with its brain
but experts in the field warned that
this is not as impressive as you may
think
as the monkey is likely not able to do
meaningful functions on the computer
like using the internet or interpreting
information on the internet
rather experts suggest that the progress
is likely to have given the monkey the
ability to move the cursor
or possibly type as a result pairing our
brains with artificial intelligence
is still quite a whiles off however
something that is
actually on the horizon is perfecting
control of artificial limbs
and more importantly giving them a
feeling of touch
this would of course be a monumental
feat for paralyzed individuals
who would love to take advantage of this
technology to regain control of their
limbs
as well as a sense of touch but anyways
moving back to its impact on education
given that the technology is just in its
infancy
we are likely to see our brains
transition into supercomputers within
our lifetimes
however what we may see this technology
enable
is limited access to the internet of
course you won't be able to watch
youtube videos or play online games
using your link anytime soon
but what we may be able to do is access
word-based media
such as articles and encyclopedias which
would eliminate the need to memorize
anything
we can access the date that the magna
carta was written as well as the entire
transcript of the federalist papers in a
split second
we will essentially be able to download
word-based information
onto our brains at will no more formula
sheets or reading books or articles
but then what will we do in school and
college
well even if such technology doesn't
come to fruition for several decades
the truth is having this information
accessible using our brains
is just a luxury as we already have it
in our pockets
sure we may not be able to process
information in a split second using our
brains
and we actually have to spend time and
effort reading and understanding
material
but we can already access everything in
just 10 seconds using our phones
and unfortunately most traditional
schooling has
yet to acknowledge the fact that this is
the new reality
and continue to teach through
memorization however
this is slowly changing as curriculums
and teachers
are evolving to accommodate for these
new resources and
this will simply accelerate with the
introduction of such technology
for instance science classes will focus
on labs and trial and error
rather than memorizing various equations
similarly
history will focus on the influence and
impact of various events
rather than the dates and names in the
meantime
companies will start to implement their
own training and certification programs
for jobs in the tech and business world
college will serve a niche audience
looking for certain degrees in medicine
and law as opposed to feeding a broad
audience generic
and often outdated material we'll have a
whole slew of people running their own
small online businesses
and schooling will switch over to
focusing on soft skills and application
as opposed to memorization and with all
of these transitions
hopefully fewer people will see school
as a monotonous chore
and more of a resource that actually
prepares them for the future for once
but that's just what i think where do
you guys see
school heading with technological
improvements comment that down below
and of course if you guys like the depth
of this analysis
then make sure to drop a like and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys
on the next one
you